if you fall into a black hole
ready go you know black holes there this
black hole is fixed and a wormhole if
different because it goes to a new you
know new world but those so it fits and
black hole deal bow I think that's your
name I couldn't quite we couldn't quite
make it out but bow greetings bill here
you're asking about black holes as great
question the way I like to describe a
black hole it's a star a black hole is a
star now when you and I think of stars
we think about the Sun which is giving
off all this light but the other thing
about the Sun to keep in mind is it has
a lot of gravity as it's huge and
everything that has mass everything that
would weigh something here on earth has
gravity and the exact origin of gravity
where it actually comes from is not
fully understood though if you could
figure that out you know you might
change the world but with that said a
black hole is a star so big how big is
it
it's a it's so big that even light
cannot escape it because it has so much
gravity one of Einstein's discoveries
Albert Einstein's discoveries was that
gravity changes the path of light it can
bend light it's just not what you're
it's just not in our everyday experience
when we're in a room like this or where
you are there's not nearly enough
gravity to bend light enough to measure
especially with just human eyes to
measure it we usually find objects way
out in space and we have known
brightness and we see where we think
they're going to be and then when they
really appear to be and then we infer or
figure out that that they don't they're
not where we thought they were going to
be because the gravity bent the beam of
light it's amazing anyway so black hole
is a star so massive that not even light
can escape from it now when you get
something that big
the gravity as you get near it changes
and you know this like if you're real
far away from a light a light bulb it's
dim right when you walk up really close
to it gets brighter and brighter and
brighter well the same is true the
gravity that's that a star produces or
anything with mass produces the closer
you are to it the more gravity it has
satellites in space have less gravity to
fight than you and I do here on the
surface once they get out there in space
for example so when you fall into a
black hole bow first of all you don't
want to do that because the difference
in gravity between your feet and your
head just that far is so powerful it
would stretch you into really really
thin like a thin as a wire thin as a
piece of spaghetti as the saying goes
and bow I don't want to shock you that
that would that be really bad but in
science fiction we love that because
that's we can fly around in spaceships
and they have sort of science fiction
magic powers and they can we can survive
stuff like that in science stories
now you mentioned wormholes wormholes
are an idea that people think may exist
and the idea is that you would fall into
something with a lot of gravity like a
black hole and instead of just getting
crushed and killed you would end up in
another part of the universe at a
different time and this is something
that physicists say to each other at
physics meetings and they oh yeah oh
yeah you different party the University
of time yeah that's great yeah piece of
cake black hole wormhole sure that's
sure but understand though nobody's ever
done this these are theoretical things
they're important theoretical things
because they are consistent or they're
part of the bigger story that
astronomers and astrophysicists and just
scientists in general they're part of
the bigger story of the universe and
where you and I came from and what we're
all doing here and why the earth goes
around the Sun and why the other planets
go around the Sun and there
all in the same plane almost except
Pluto which is going on so it's all part
of this big story so these are great
questions Bo but they really don't have
clear succinct answers right now but
perhaps you will be the scientist the
astrophysicist who figures this out for
sure when you have these objects or
these theoretical places in space that
seemed to have so much energy you just
got to wonder if we could harness that
energy and do something fantastic with
it keep asking questions Bo is great
carry on
you